maybe with the beating he's getting he's
going to learn some skills he can learn
later on in life hey guys I'm off the
grid for August and hopefully not seeing
Anna Navarro wherever I am right now but
she's still at it at the view here you
go
30 points under Donald Trump who's got
two indictments and possibly a third and
fourth before this month is over and I
would say to Rhonda santis maybe maybe
the first thing you should start doing
is stop fighting with black Republicans
who are telling you to stop defending
the standards about slavery that you are
trying to make part of the curriculum in
Florida I mean what is it that he said
learned skills that they could use later
on in life well maybe with the beating
he's getting he's going to learn some
skills he can learn later on in life
like humility or Compassion or
self-awareness